Salut ! Ce soir je vais jouer au Palais des Glaces Pour rire de résistance.
C'est un spectacle qui est organisé pour soutenir l'association "Le Rire Médecin"
On est pas mal de personnes à se retrouver sur cette scène. Donc, je prépare mes petites affaires.
Voilà ! Il y a un annuaire, une petite brosse pour mes cheveux, un posca, au cas où !
Je ne sais même pas si on me voit là...
Et puis, comme je ne sais pas si vous avez déjà vu l'intérieur du Palais des Glaces, je vous mets dans ma valise !
Je viens d'arriver au Palais des Glaces, et je vous fais découvrir le couloir,
Avec les portraits des "Grands" qui sont déja passés ici.
"Rohlala" ! Pierre Palmade, c'est à ce moment là que tu te dis qu'il est passé il y'a longtemps quand même...
Qui c'est qu'on a ? Les Vamps,
Elie et Dieudonné...  Oui ils ont été ensemble un moment donné... On a la preuve !
Dany Boon !
Mais, dis donc ! Ce ne serait pas les loges du Palais des Glaces ?!
Avec Céline Holynski et Olivia Moore !
Olivia: Incroyable !
Fabien: Tu joues sur Scène ce soir ? Celine: Non, je suis venue que pour les bonbons !
Fabien: Olivia , elle m'a dit oui pour faire une vidéo, tout à l'heure.
Olivia: Je dis Oui !
Et je peux vous dire que ça bosse ! C'est Patrick Chanfray qui présente ce soir.
Comme ça ouvre dans 2 minutes, on se disait qu'on était large !
Si je filme une caméra qui filme, Est-ce que c'est une mise en abîme ?
Patrick: Non, mais ça peut abimer ta caméra !
Fabien: ah ! M*r*e
Artus: Hey ! C'est Fabien Olicard, aujourd'hui je vais mentaliser, Aymeric Lompret !
Alors, Aymeric Lompret, heuuuu (dédicace Fabien) Pense à un chiffre...
Tu l'as dit tout haut, du coup je l'ai entendu.
Vas-y refait ! Essaye de ne pas parler. Pense à un chiffre entre 1 et 3...
Aymeric: Inclus ?
Artus: Non, pas 1 ni 3 Aymerick: C'est bon, j'ai...
Tu t'en souviens ? Maintenant, je te fais un autre tour, garde ton chiffre en tête.
Je vais me tourner. Tu choisis un doigt, tu le touche. Tu ne me dis surtout pas lequel. tu t'en souviens ?
[rire]
Je mélange...
C'est celui là !
Aymerick: C'est ça ! Et le chiffre ?
Artus: Et le chiffre, c'était le 2
Aymerick: Oui [rire]
Voilà ! On se retrouve demain, pour un nouveau Mental "Blog", avec d'autres tours un peu "fifou"
Aymerick: Il est balaize !
Artus: Sortie de stade de France ! Merci, Eh ! Il est balaize [rire]